brauchen sie das finde ich mich als
sympathisch und attraktiv bleiben was
ist das für eine schauspielerische was
für uns gefunden was uns heute anschauen
werden das ist heftig wie wir das gleich
zusammen video anschauen was die bisher
bekannten maßstäbe von schlechtgemacht
menschlich gesehen zu nicht abstoßen und
einfach ruiniert so was von spreng wird
das habt ihr noch nicht gesehen ich habe
schon mal kurze video angeschaut weil
ich kann mich so viel sagen das ist
wirklich so schlimm wie es gerade ihn
beschrieben habe ich will auch gar nicht
so viel vorneweg reden nur eine sache
würde ich sagen leute weil ich glaube
ich auch sagen muss vor diesem video was
wir gleich sehen werden ist eine fiktive
handlung okay das ist eine ausgedachte
handlung dies nicht echt und wenn ich
mich über diese fiktive also ausgedachte
handlung lustig mache heißt es nicht
dass ich mich über die damit gemeinte
echte sache lustig machen okay das sind
zwei paar schuhe dementsprechend heute
nimmt sich zu ernst und jetzt viel spaß
bei manchen reaktion auf kranke liebe
doktor in der psycho falle
[Musik]
ich kann ja wirklich mehr doch okay
leute ich glaube wir wissen jetzt auch
was ich gerade eben gemeinsam einem
kleinen präsent wo wir sehen hier eine
mädchen was er von der brücke steht und
sie redet auch nicht allzu gut
geschauspielert weise mit sich selbst
und sagte ja eigentlich kein wort egal
ich mache jetzt ein körper jedoch
gestapelt oder nicht schon eher die
scheißegal ist mir scheißegal
okay das gerade eben leute wie seit
nimmt sich auch hier der spaß los ja so
also wir sind mitten in der pampa okay
wir sind mitten im nirgendwo habt ihr
gerade eben gesehen das ist eine brücke
keine ahnung dagegen wahrscheinlich im
jahr drei menschen drüber nach und sieht
das so und ist so auch gepackt ich habe
ich kann also ich glaube natürlich
fahren genau in dem moment diese zwei
polizisten streife im wald warum warum
fahren die streifen wald sind die gerade
hinter irgendwelchen bahn daher oder was
da los
[Musik]
was ist denn los was machst du hier wir
können nicht abhauen
das ist unser beruf ist unser beruf
streifen wald zu fahren ok und du hältst
du's nicht davon ab kriminelle
eichhörnchen festzunehmen
außer der dialog davor hey was machst du
da geh' weg lasst mich alleine
wir können nicht weg es ist unser beruf
die schauspielerei system ist wieder
richtig wohl gar nicht an
das geht sehr wohl was was du nicht
wirklich streng leute es liebt sich von
hinten anleger erst legt sich von hinten
an achtet auf den blick in seinen augen
erst so okay ich hab ihm planen ich
nehme jetzt anlauf und dann mache ich
einen doppelten vorwärtssalto von dieser
brücke runter und da bin ich der king
glauben ihr das leben ist schön
was bringt mir das was du hast also
leute wie gesagt noch mal bitte denkt
nach lebt das nicht ewig können ist aber
lustig war das ist eine fiktive
situation wir betreiben es aber auch
nicht also mit kopf okay jetzt aber
diese dialoge
es ist egal es ist einfach es ist
wirklich einfach grausam
es ist so schlecht gemacht die haben
auch in dem moment in dem sie sie quasi
geparkt haben haben wir auch gesagt wir
haben dich ja nicht er hat mich ja
vielen dank für den formationen hat er
mich überhaupt kein gefühl in keinem
körperteil ich in den abend nicht im
rumpf sich in den beinen danke für die
informationen dass sie mich jetzt habt
königstein ja es ist wirklich also das
ist wirklich so schmerzhaft getauscht
werden leute ihr habt ja mit mir schon
einige hilfen wir wollen geschaut dass
das sticht wirklich heraus unter all
diesen folgen die alle keinen wirklich
gerne hollywood produktionen sind sticht
das wirklich heraus wie ein schwarzes
schaf mich raus wie sie auch immer so
genau im exakt gleichen rhythmus an die
tür klopft es ist einfach so es ist so
schlecht gemacht
[Musik]
es geht also weiter
wenn es mit dieser frau los alter ohne
witz ich glaube wenn du jetzt nicht den
experten gebildet hätten
die halbe stunde weiter gemacht ich will
raus
ich will hier nicht sein wann bekomme
ich endlich den oscar für die beste
weibliche hauptrolle
ach ja und davon mal abgesehen was hatte
ich erwartet was passiert sie hat ja
also fiktive geschichte wie gesagt ne
aber in dieser fiktiven geschichte hat
sie irgendwie versucht sich selbst zu
schaden sie von der polizei festgenommen
und dann sagt sie so ich bin voll
gericht lasst mich raus ach so ja auch
immer kommen die polizisten reinach so
durch diesen volljährig ja dann bitte
keine ahnung hatten sie sich eine axt
ins bein
machen sie eine seite und die
brennesseln wie sie wollen sie mir vor
gericht hallo ich bin dr martens
erstens warum ist jetzt so drauf und
zweitens was war das für ein match in
schalter von ich muss da heraus
innerhalb von 0 5 sekunden in denen
doktor einläuft zu
[Musik]
ich bin einer der psychologen hier in
der not unterkommen und ich werde bei
ihnen die aufnahme und mädchen es ist
eine ernste situation okay du bist jetzt
hier an einem ort wo leute dir helfen
wollen
das ist nicht kinder okay es ist noch
nicht lang und auch nicht elitepartner
also setzte ich auf deine studie lass
dir helfen verdammte kacke
sie läuft ja so als würde einfach nur
helfen die bisher jerry's exportmodell
film im kopf sie sind nun israelis zum
ich nur meine mutter wenn ich stopp
musste mario matt ö
also ich muss sagen mal okay du hast
immer noch nicht verstanden wo du bist
du bist in einer nervenheilanstalt oder
sonstwo hat quasi klappt so ja wo leute
wir helfen wollen weil du schon ein rad
ab hast oder weiß vielleicht geht ja was
sollte da wohl eins raus zu nehm ich mir
meine mutter wenn ich bock mist gebaut
habe
ich hoffe eine ernste lage ist ihm klar
sie wollen zwangseingewiesen künftiger
details einfach nichts sie weiß nicht ob
tiger dies komplett in ihrem germany's
next topmodel kinderfilm geht durch
dieses gesicht ist dass das gesicht von
jemandem dem dem schlecht geht und der
hilfe braucht
doch die geht komplett an der situation
vorbei denkt wirklich es geht darum
jetzt das nächste foto von heidi zu
bekommen selbst der arzt sagt zu ihr so
textur überhaupt was gerade abgeht
mädchen so hast du glauben planen dass
hier gerade passiert außerdem warten
steht
sie haben keine eltern mehr
sie sind so ein junges attraktives
nettes mädchen
sorry dj runway das ist die ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz falsche richtung und
biber arzt eigentlich sollte erst als
fachmann besserwissen okay sie konnten
sich wahrscheinlich nicht im vollbesitz
ihrer kräfte irgendwas geht ab so die
datenrate ok und sie flirte mit ihm so
alles klar soweit auch immer geht der
arzt auf ein und sagte ihr dass sie ein
attraktives mädchen ist dicker nein
nicht diesen weg einschlagen warum haben
sie das
wenn ich mich als sympathisch und
attraktiv ist kann ich erst was ist das
für eine schauspielerei du findest dich
als sympathisch und attraktiv
also das ist wirklich den vogel ab also
wären wir schon viel gesehen auf dem
hilfen den kanal uns hat diese sätze aus
deutschland erhalten aber das ist
wirklich können wir so den hilfen wie
oskar einführen für so die schlechteste
schauspielerische darstellung haben die
nicht stoppt nicht weiter in diese
richtung noch mal es ist nicht
hindermann ihr seid in der
arzt-patienten-beziehung und es geht
darum dass man jemandem hilft und zwar
bleibe ich liebend gern
ach ja ja ich wohne ja ich wohne am
arbeitsplatz ja klar
so wie alle menschen in deutschland
wohne ich an meinem arbeitsplatz sowie
der der bäcker der in der bäckerei und
die beckers über nacht dann meistens im
ofen nach ist tatsächlich piloten so die
die schlafen natürlich im flugzeug sehr
klar hinten lassen sie das und ich bin
übrigens gesiezt werden
ich bin schließlich ihr psychologie und
nicht ihren kumpeln lassen sie was
achtung jetzt leute sind sich so hin
ich will mit ihnen flirten gehen sie mit
mir eine beziehung ein
und ich kann noch viel mehr
also erstens nein er will es nicht also
zumindest das was du willst also die
helfen du keine ahnung wie es mit dem
vierten das will er nicht und du kannst
noch viel mehr erläutert ist gehört sie
kann noch mehr als die uns schon gezeigt
hat
nun ist das wahnsinn noch noch besser
schauspielern noch öfter dreimal gegen
eine tür horn okay leute ich glaube
jetzt kommt wieder so hilf mir typisch
auch relativ viel gelaber so
zwischendrin ich will einfach noch mal
wissen so wie ich will und was ihr
wirklich diese folge aus
minute sechs im springen über es nach
hinten die leute ja ich hab es indes
gibt und es wird ehren los gar nicht so
viel 20 sekunden später nach der stelle
wo der bedarf eben schon waren wird es
ihren los und dann ist alles gesagt über
diese folge und zwar tut sie so als
hätte sie eine panikattacke und drückt
diesen notknopf und dann ruhig
schon heute 70 oder deinen worten ich
will dieses video nicht weiter anschauen
ich habe keinen bock mehr auf die bezüge
zu viel mehr leute wunderbar wunderbar
ja sehr sehr hochwertiges video was uns
da gar dem rhein gezogen haben freut
mich dass hier wieder eingeschaltet habt
ja toll vor sich dieses kommentare was
sie heute gesehen habe gefallen hat
würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr meinen
kanal abonniert und hier drüben ein
vorstand ist die optik und das war weit
von mir ich könnt eure augen bis zum
nächsten mal